[Music]
we begin this half-hour with a dream
vacation for book lovers and the
remarkable story behind it it involves
an American woman a Scottish bookstore
and the many visitors who get to live
out a nonfiction fantasy Jonathan
Vigliotti reports there's no easy way to
get to wig town planes and trains stop
hours shy of the remote village on
Scotland's sea swept west coast with so
much peace and quiet it almost makes
sense at the tiny town population 900
has 14 yes 14 book themed shops but
nothing compares to the relative
newcomer the open book whose simple
shelves of used novels and nonfiction
are attracting book lovers from all over
the world I had a bit of a look into it
books I'm an English teacher Christy
Vedado is an English teacher with a
dream of owning her own bookshop and
here at the open book that dream is
brought to life I'm Christian by the way
a rotating cast of tourists get the keys
to their very own bookshop it's part of
a unique Airbnb listing by aspiring Los
Angeles screenwriter Jessica Fox what is
it about books that attracts you so much
the lifestyle it is the lifestyle you
know it's really odd because I'm not a
big reader the things way better the
open book feels like it belongs in a
movie all of it the product of Fox's
imagination I knew it was Scotland I
kind of see myself in this like wooly
jumper I could like hear the rain
outside I could like smell the bookshop
I could see myself behind the counter
reading about Google lead Jessica - Whig
town and when her Airbnb listing went
live in 2015 many followed there was a
couple in their 80s who had just gotten
married and they did this is a honeymoon
so already that's quite amazing and
you've got the bedroom in here the
bookshop and it's upstairs living
quarters are booked through 2020
and then a rocking chair near the window
guests at the open book pay about $50 a
night to work for free they can change
the window displays business hours and
even the prices but with so many
bookshops and so few residents visitors
tend to read more than they sell
including words of wisdom from previous
shopkeepers it's a lot of people who
have worked here have have have a green
few plays James Taylor people like slow
down and like read more books and will
buy more books secret to book shops
other tips of the temporary trade are
penned in the open books diary except
all or as many possible invitations from
local residents who stop by the shop
people in wig town are very friendly so
make it a priority to meet them thank
you for Christie this is a holiday for
the imagination
a world that in one week's time will be
handed over to another wonder list
what's it like to be sitting in the
middle of your dream now realized like I
guess then the real question is like
what do I dream next for CBS this
morning Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti wig
town Scotland I think I need to a book
about two months in that bookstore yeah
I need a woolly jumper it's pretty
amazing